those dead eyes yeah pretty good there
is a debate going on about how they did
luke skywalker in the mandalorian so
here's what we're going to do we're
going to make a defect luke skywalker
we're going to show you how we do it
literally asking can we do better than a
multi-billion dollar company called
disney
we might be able to
[Music]
the hardest thing to do in visual
effects is to create a digital
human being from nothing now spoiler
alert if you're watching the mandalorian
and you haven't finished season two
maybe stop watching this video
okay spoiler alert over luke skywalker
showed up pretty neat kind of had a lot
of mixed reviews as to how it looked and
a lot of contention as to how it was
done because disney has been very secret
that's how they did it now in vfx artist
react we do a lot of critiques but today
we're going to put our money where our
mouth is we're trying to create our own
version of luke skywalker
it's more realistic more emotive and
more vibrant and lifelike than what
disney has created
we're going to be doing a deep fake what
you're about to see is not
really tom cruise someone took the
computer
and they made him say and do things he
wouldn't say now watch and remember
this is not tom cru ready run the bell
yeah to get a little subscription plus
action yeah and i'm having the time in
my life
it's such an honor oh it's an honor and
a privilege don't forget that
now i cannot overstate how big of a deal
this is if we pull this off
because it represents a fundamental
shift in how visual effects are going to
be done in the industry
we're reaching a point where ai and
machine learning can potentially
let anyone create a shot that has before
just been impossible
so come along for the ride let's see if
we do it alright guys we have some
important very important business to
discuss was luke skywalker deep faked in
the final episode of the mandalorian
there is a debate going on about how
they did luke skywalker in the
mandalorian
i was fairly certain when i first saw it
that it wasn't a deep fake because it
looked more to me
like moff tarkin or princess leia from
rogue one very classic pipeline sort of
cgi
rather than experimental one person
doing it on youtube deep fake
style stuff now the thing is to do it
for a tv show for like a 10 second scene
at the end of an episode
it's pretty nuts because you'd have to
make 3d models you'd have to do face
tracking you have to animation like so
much work would have to go
into it did you know that disney
actually developed their own defect
method and they released a whole
technical paper and video about it
what they did for luke there it does
look like there's some element of deep
fakery going on
the challenge they were facing is that
the person who is playing luke in the
actual shot that they have to film with
the camera is not mark hamill so they
need to get mark hamill's performance
stick that onto that person's face so i
think they're dealing with like a double
stack here they have an actor who then
either has a cg
like 3d head or mark hamill's actual
like face
being tracked on top of that and then
you have a defect being applied on top
of that now you're basically stuck with
a double stepping
kind of situation and that's where i'm
wondering if we could surpass them
you're literally asking can we do better
than a multi-billion dollar company
called disney
we might be able to step one so we're
gonna try to figure out how we can
improve
this shot so little things we can look
for here the shadow is hand
passing across the space like does it
look defined or does it look blurry
right the lighting is very soft and kind
of an omnidirectional light compared to
all the defined
sharp lighting and the rest of the
scenes it makes it kind of feel flat and
washed out almost like airbrushed in
how light interacts with stuff is what
makes it feel real so if we can be
hitting that scene with a lot of
directional light we can really give
things a sense of form and shape we have
flickering lights and moving light
sources and all these things that can
just really
help us sell that this is a real thing
look how light interacts with it you can
do this easily if it was fake look for
those dead eyes
yeah pretty good your eyes never just
drift they always
lock lock lock when he raises his head
his eyes just
smoothly move up like if you look at how
his mouth moves that feels like keyframe
targets to me doesn't that
a little bit all these heads have very
smooth movement they're like
cute framed so smoothly got that s curve
moving around whereas human heads like
will like vigorously shake sometimes and
we have kind of erratic movements in our
heads
people's expressions are connected like
when i smile this happens this happens
you know when i raise my eyebrows my
mouth twitches
the biggest takeaway from that scene is
just how stiff the performance is
period i feel like they're very locked
in in a box and they can't turn his head
too much or have them make big
expressions because probably worried
about how realistic it's going to look
now if we can make our version of luke
emotive and give smiles and
you know eyes that are vibrant they look
around that's all going to really
help sell this is an actual character
because as a visual effects artist you
know one half of your job
is actually constructing these elements
that's going to go into a shot the other
part
is all the little tricks that are going
to sell it as real it's classic
visual trickery if we can do all that we
can make a better luke skywalker
we're going to use artificial
intelligence we're going to use machine
learning
we're going to be doing a deep fake dpix
going to let us put a luke skywalker
mask
on an actor it's basically a computer
practicing to be a portraiture artist
it's looking at somebody's face and it
kind of paints a version of it it looks
kind of blurry and weird but if it
practices it over and over and over
and retains its memory as to what worked
well then you end up with a computer
that can draw somebody's face pretty
well and the magic of a deep fake comes
from a computer learning to draw one
person's face
another person's face and then you
switch the wires the nice thing about
deep fig is all the stuff i talked about
motion lighting expression even
perspective you get all that without
having to build out 3d models and deal
with all the crazy physics simulations
you need to do to get a face to look
realistic the way we're gonna make the
deep fake is well documented
you can look up tutorials online we're
just going to be doing the same thing
now we have a couple tricks of our sleep
first
nvidia 30 90 gpu incredibly fast
incredibly powerful
a lot of vram so you can get some nice
higher resolution deep fakes puget
systems
has been building us workstations here
at corridor and that's gonna be our
go-to machine for making this deep fake
it's gonna let us get to a higher
quality version luke skywalker
higher resolution in a shorter amount of
time than any other computer here in
this office
you're going to be seeing a cutting edge
deep fake here so the key ingredient for
a deep fake when you're drawing a face
is you need to feed the computer
examples in the face
we need to inform the computer and how
to draw luke skywalker so really the
only version of luke skywalker we can
use is the one that we see in return
legitima so i'm going to enlist peter
here be my teammate
together we're going to try to gather as
many high quality pictures of luke
skywalker as possible
every angle every pose and every
lighting condition return of the jedi
was released in the 80s it was still
shot on film
which can be great quality and some of
these shots are great quality but
a lot of them are just blurry as hell
and that's causing problems because the
images you feed in
is the kind of image you're gonna get
out then we're gonna have a blurry deep
fake and so right now i'm trying to use
these different
ai sharpening tools and some of them are
giving some
wacky results oh my gosh here is a i
sharpened blue
so it's just scary we've gone and found
a bunch of pictures of luke skywalker
but now we need to find our actor who's
going to wear the deep face who's going
to play
our luke skywalker because all the deep
fake is is a mask
everything else we gotta do for real
still closer we can get to someone that
looks like mark hamill
from return of the jedi the better can i
volunteer
i don't want any part of this wait
luke
but i was going to go to tashi station
to pick up some power converters
there he is i've been waiting my whole
life for this moment
dean has the exact same chin by the time
we're done with you they won't even
recognize you
man i was hoping to be a jetty oh yeah
dude i probably look the most like baby
yoda
it's between you and sam well we found
our luke skywalker
and dean hughes all along who would have
thought so now we know it's dean we need
to capture pictures of dean so the
computer can practice
recreating dean's face remember it's
about being able to look at and draw
dean's face look at and draw luke's face
and then cross the wires in the middle
we're gonna film dean under a bunch of
lighting conditions making a bunch of
expressions from a bunch of different
angles i definitely have enough data to
start this training this is actually
great this is like
a lot of really good like lighting
samples so now we have our dean images
and we have our luke skywalker images
and the computer is training on those
practicing drawing dean practicing
drawing luke it's practicing drawing
luke on dean but this takes time and it
totally depends on the quality of the
pictures that we have
so it's imperative that we have this
defect running as much as possible is
made to get this trained
on a 30-90 is still probably going to
take us about 10 days maybe a little bit
less
everything needs to be set up to be
running all weekend because we can't
afford to lose that time
man look at this look at this dean dean
you're you're starting to turn into mark
hamill man look at you
don't look at that one the most we can
do right now is just step back
and let it run
[Music]
oh hey i don't know if you know this but
the guys are at the studio
right now and they're doing something
that has to do with the mandalorian
season two now i haven't seen it yet and
i don't want to know
anything about it so i've been holed up
here in my attic with one purpose and
one purpose only
raid chat alleges courtesy of today's
sponsor that's right one thing we like
to do around here at corridor is play
little dungeons and dragons and if you
like dungeons and dragons and you like
mobile games well
then you might also like great chatter
legends too the thing that i like the
best about it is that you can pick
and choose how you want to play the game
they have everything from straight up
arena battles
to campaigns to dungeon battles where
you can team up with
friends and actually go in with your
buddies you don't need to wait on
anybody to play but you can also play
with people whenever you want another
thing you can do is
summon different champions and level
them up as you play the game now the
fastest way to level up a champion is
through farming a campaign you grind xp
and get loads of silver at the same time
picking and choosing champions is some
of the most fun that i have in the game
and i got i get hey hey little buddy
what look at that guy right there i mean
he's one of the champions right there
you could pick him you could level him
up you can put him in an arena battle
you can put him in a campaign it doesn't
matter because rage had a legend
has it all that's right they've got
fights with noble knights and dark
wizards
they've got tough bosses they've got
millions of players and best of all
they've got years of content and regular
updates so that whenever you jump on and
play the game whether you download it
now or whether you download it six
months ago
there will always be something new for
you recently raids developers rolled out
the biggest update ever
the doom tower that's right it's a giant
tower with 120 floors a bunch of secret
challenge rooms and 12 seriously badass
bosses to take on so
if you're interested now is a really
good time to try raid chat legends
yeah what do you think you think that's
good
i don't know what to do with that do you
live up here
do you live up here so if you're
interested hit the link in the
description
to redeem your free void champion an xp
booster
50 gems some energy refills and an
ancient shard
also check out this champion bulwark
you'll get for free it'll be a huge help
probably in the doom tower get on that
right now
anyway look at the time it's time to get
back to work i think the guys have
passed
through this mandalorian spoilers phase
i'm going to check in with them
the coast is clear from here hey honey
yeah
they do you think luke skywalker did you
know damn it
we've been talking a lot about what
we're going to try to create here we're
going to try to redo
the scene the mandalorian now you may
have seen like other deep fakes in line
where they defeat that scene
but they're just putting a deep fake on
top of the scene that already exists but
in this case we're starting from scratch
we're going to have our own actor their
own hair and makeup on a blue screen
with our own cg background the entire
thing is going to be us
so what we learned with our tom cruise
deep fake is that performance
posture body language all these things
your hair those all matter
so dean is not an actor but he loves
star wars so i try to get my hair like a
little more
looky all right i'm george lucas i want
to see you walk into this room and i
want to see you take your hood off
with gravitas okay
[Music]
he needs to be the puppet master driving
the expression you know
if dean's smiling in a way that luke
skywalker never smiles because mark
campbell doesn't smile that way it
doesn't matter how good the t-pick is
it's not gonna match we're gonna go
comas air make this happen if we pull
this off we got our shot
all right we're about to start filming
our shots we're filming on a green
screen we're setting up
all the lighting like all the ways i
talked about so i can bring this to life
we're gonna get demon costume i'm gonna
put him in the scene i'm gonna realize
his lifelong dream bring your child to
work day
i made a whole shot list of all the
lines how i want to do a performance
around them i've been working on some
effects with the lights to like simulate
sparks and things like that
you know at this point we just got to
shoot it and see what happens all right
all mysterious
you just came into the smoke action
does it occur to you that mark hamill
himself might actually see this that
might be the best moment in my life
dean is more of a puppet master than he
is an actor right now he needs to
puppeteer our deep fake so
for him to puppeteer effectively he
needs to move his face
like mark hamill does all right good
work nice work
good acting d got everything we need
right
on this guy uh it was the best day of my
life so
just gonna go back to work can i
can i keep costume you can keep the
costume on the shoe with dean
went great it worked far better than i
had any like hope
for it to work the green lightsaber on
his face the flickering sparks
it all worked it's really cool but we
have a bunch of problems
oh look at that look at that
look at that lighting look at that
lifelike natural
luke expression look at these dreams
being realized luke's hair is definitely
puffier though
luke's got the helmet thing going on we
need to shoot it again with the wig it's
gonna be it's not a big deal
dean's neck is longer his jaw's a little
bit wider his shoulders are a little bit
more slouched
and dean's eyebrows are a little bit
lower to his eyes so once you put luke
skywalker on him it looks like luke's
doing this the whole time and he's just
walking around the neutral like frown
expression
and there's no way we could have known
any of this until we did it
we clearly need to go back reshoot it
again but we have a lot more knowledge
about what's going to make this look
realistic we need to get the hair right
the hair
is not working you get the posture right
when you get the body type right but the
lighting
no i'm going to do more of that we're
taking the shot to the next level today
jordan went and got us some wigs
that's right that wasn't my real hair
could you tell
this is what we need to use if we ever
want to do a nico fake is this freaking
anchorman dude yeah
the background looks really good it's
too wavy this is
too short on the side this part is not
right yeah
it's not gonna work i'm telling you dude
the color's not that big of a deal we
can always alter the color george is
coming i can literally show him this
picture in that wig i'm like dude can
you cut this in that hairstyle
absolutely is that the wig right there
that's the wig all right we're looking
for
something like this okay totally by
coincidence today
we were doing haircuts before work
started anyway because a lot of the
dudes
wanted haircuts because they haven't had
them in a long time so george is
actually going to help out and cut the
wig into
the closest luke skywalker style you can
close very close
the colors a little tricky but dean
needs to put on some masks and i think
the only way to do that
is to just have him do some pull-ups and
then we'll stuff them with some rags and
stuff but i think you got to like get
the base layer until failure till
failure
bigger all right let's do this let's put
on the full cup
it does it does shorten my neck a little
bit it does if you haven't locked it in
i just want to see if you want to hit
the cut off
it's looking good it looks awesome the
wig
huge help it's not perfect but it's way
better dean's performance
much better much more lighting we got
his posture he looks way more regal
you know we padded up those shoulders
either way i'm really excited but here's
what we got to do now the deep fake is
doing its final final final little bit
of training
we need to composite in cg backgrounds
which we are just like disregarding as a
challenge
like that's a challenge still pulling a
good blue screen key and doing cg
backgrounds is still hard
how's it going here it's going really
good dude it's
friday this video is coming out on
sunday and we're still working on it
the reason we're still working on it is
because we have seen the potential
and we are doing our best to make this
as good as we possibly can
dude defects gotta be deep we're doing
our compositing
you know taking our new luke skywalker
and putting him on our new background
that we've created
like i just took it for granted that
we'd be able to you know have a
3d hallway behind luke with like lights
flickering and all that kind of stuff
like i'll figure that out later because
you know i've done that before
so peter's just been cranking through
that as fast as he can yeah just taking
the original shot from mandalorian
building out the geometry based on what
was in that scene i
imported a frame from the show into this
program called f-spy
which is super useful you like specify
some straight lines in the scene
and then the software interprets that
and gives you the exact camera position
and you can just throw that into blender
and then you have the scene from the
movie
perfectly lined up with your 3d view so
then you can start dropping in blocks
and
panels and stuff and start lining it up
so it matches perfectly
so what you've got to do for the
corridor crew channel is to subscribe if
you don't subscribe my voice will go
back to being normal and i'll be very
sad but if you do subscribe i'll
continue talking like this forever
if you're wondering why i'm even doing
this is because i'm going to make a
video showing how many
balloons would really be needed to lift
the house from up
subscribe for that
i've been training on this deep fake for
two weeks we have almost a million
iterations meaning like peter has looked
at a face over and over a million times
you know as we dialed this in here you
have to also match the colors of the
film you have to match the other shots
like all the things that aren't deep
fake related just normal visual effects
production related
and then there's a whole doesn't look
like luke skywalker thing
we'll see if it paid off i'm just i just
wanna like at this point i've been
staring at it forever
so yeah let's go get everybody
hey guys do you want to see the
mandalorian but with our version of luke
skywalker
yeah is it time
all right guys uh we've all been working
super hard on this i hope it's cool
we'll see you guys tell me
[Music]
are you a jedi
i am
[Music]
he doesn't want to go with you
he wants your permission
he is strong with the force but talent
without training is nothing
[Music]
may the force be with you
okay here we go
[Music]
did we achieve your dreams you know
what's crazy about it is that like it
looks amazing
but there's like five and some shots
even like ten percent dean in there
blue skywalker's is ten percent deemed
mark hamill if you're watching this
you can have my body anytime
[Laughter]
the sparks look pretty freaking sweet
and if you look closely you actually see
the highlights and the eyeballs move too
it's crazy
the likeness is still not a hundred
percent
but it is way closer way sharper and it
has way more
emotion defects definitely a viable way
to bring old characters back to life and
if anybody's at disney's watching this
like it's like a very fancy uh resume
application right now
we're all like kind of worn out like
we've been running like full focus
not just today but like this entire week
all right
deep fix pretty cool we've done other
experiments with defects in the channel
you should check out
fixing the worst vfx shot of all time
keanu reeves stops a robbery and the one
we did with tom cruise which
is no longer accurate but at the time we
labeled it the best deep fake on the
internet
i want to know what you guys think did
we do better or worse was it more
vibrant or was it really weird and kind
of creepy
it's your guys's turn to be the vfx
artist reacting
in vfx rs react and we're on display
here so
yeah i'm going to read all those
comments it's one of my favorite things
to do yeah
give us some breakdowns give us some
critiques i want to see it subscribe